hi
thank you for joining us on our research
summit meeting to discuss the future of
medicine and innovation my name is janae
badger i'm the chief medical scientist
at microsoft research based out of our
cambridge labs
um i'm so grateful for
mike rosenblatt joining us
today thinking about his role as a
distinguished clinician academic and
life sciences leader
mike is someone that i've known by
reputation for a number of years and
more recently i've wanted to know both
as a colleague and a mentor mike thank
you so much for joining us and taking
time out of your precious diary to share
with us some of your insights and
experiences on the future of medicine
and innovation
thank you jay thank you so much for
inviting me i'm i'm really honored to be
part of this microsoft research summit
thank you so i know you very well and
many of our viewers and attendees do not
and i wondered if you could start by
just telling us your story tell us what
you're doing now and tell us what led
you into the industry
yeah
sure i'd be happy to it it's a long
story and i'll try to
make it short so i'm a physician
scientist i'm an endocrinologist
by training and
i started out in academia trained at the
massachusetts general hospital
and became
the head of endocrinology there
at a fairly young age and
when i got that post i remember going
home and telling my wife well
you know this is one of the historic
positions in endocrinology
in the us
and we can finally unpack our bags
because i'm going to be here for
my career
and of course it didn't turn out that
way i soon after i took that position i
got asked to be a consultant to merck to
u.s merck
and i began to
travel there a few times a year
and
a few things happened there one was that
i saw that
despite
what some people in my academic
environment thought
the people i was interacting with in
industry were really top-notch
and there were no issues there
and secondly i really got the
translational science translational
medicine
bug
because i was writing grants to the nih
and in them i would always say something
like if this research goes well
the insights could lead to a new drug
but the chances of that happening in the
environment i was in
much as i loved it were very slim and
then i could see that it was actually
happening in the environment that i was
consulting to
so about um
three years later i got asked to join
merck
and had about a third of merck's
research
uh it was a very challenging opportunity
and i decided that i was really serious
about
making new therapies uh and there's
another factor that you made and that
was a very personal which was
that um i didn't harbor prejudices
against
industry or the for-profit sector the
way that many of my colleagues in
academia did
my mom took over my dad's business when
he passed away when i was a boy
and she stepped in and took it over and
she had just two young children at home
and nobody else to talk to and she'd
come home she'd talk about the
challenges and the interesting things
she was facing
in her industry and i thought these are
really important challenges uh and uh
nothing wrong with them so that was the
other factor that i would say enabled me
to make a jump that maybe
other people didn't
um once i had done that that liberated
me in a way
that would not have happened if i stayed
on my sort of predicted career track
in academic medicine
rising through the ranks
so i was at merck for about 10 years
i had the privilege of developing a drug
for osteoporosis and then i had a chance
to come back
got recruited back to boston to head a
harvard mit joint venture
called health sciences and technology
i wanted at that point to be giving back
to be involved
in education
uh and while i was doing that
there was a lot going on in the
healthcare sector in boston
intense competition
and at that point my laboratory was at
the beth israel deaconess medical center
and um it was really financially
stressed at the time and so i got asked
to make to become the president
which was kind of a left turn wasn't in
my plans
a whole new set of challenges
uh i
did that but i also learned that my
heart was much more
in the science and so after a couple of
years of doing that
i got an opportunity to take a
sabbatical
at mit
and then kind of recharge my research
batteries
and then moved to tufts as the dean of
the medical school
really embedded myself in research
and clinical medicine
and frankly and got involved in starting
some biotech companies and advising
didn't think i'd go back to industry
and then merck came along for a second
time and asked me to be the chief
medical officer their first
chief medical officer
great position global medical issues
and then finally about a little under
five years ago
i had been commuting from boston to
new jersey and i decided that i wanted
to
work in the same geography that i lived
in
and started looking around and got an
opportunity to be flagship pioneering's
first
chief medical officer uh
a position we can talk about if
if there's interest but a very exciting
opportunity in a sector that is just
growing
like crazy the biotech sector
uh
flagship is starting some very
interesting companies and so i got to be
involved
in that and uh
and now i'm a senior partner
at the firm and
pretty much at that translational
interface how do you think about
brand new technologies and bringing them
to the benefit of the patient
and if i may just reflect i mean
you you talk about it as opportunities
that have come but you've almost had
extraordinary careers within a single
lifetime if i may be so bold and you
continue to have a distinguished career
and everything that you touch and you've
been part of
some of the biggest medicines of our
time and so people here flagship they
don't probably realize that that is
in essence what's led to us having
moderna today and you've been
part of the madonna strategy for some
time maybe we can come to that when you
talk about that you're also part of uh
what happened with katruda the biggest
immunology product of our time and
arguably perhaps one of the biggest uh
pharmaceutical products of a generation
that we'll have
and then prior to that in addition
academia being top of the game so i
think it's it's extraordinary
the lessons you've learned and the
experiences that you've had from
academia to life sciences to clinical
practice and i i wonder i mean what what
drives you mike and and what is your
north star
well
well thanks for all those nice
comments some would say that i can't
make up my mind and some would say i
can't hold a job as i go back and forth
um
no uh my north star i would say uh one
you've heard about what is kind of
translation
and translation at scale i
when i was involved in uh fosmex at
merck and that's
probably the leading osteoporosis
therapy
in the world
and it became very clear to me that
i could do more good
by
helping to invent a new medicine
in total then
seeing one patient after another which
by the way i loved but that's a much
different scale
and different process so i really love
the
taking science which is so rich now
especially the science is fundamental to
medicine
and trying to bring them to the benefit
of patients
the other thing is
kind of doing the right thing
and helping so part of my cultural
background has been
that i'm from an immigrant family
and uh
you know it's the
the opportunity that i've had
has been so terrific
that i've really wanted to give back so
i've been
very focused on
the ethics
of medicine
uh you mentioned the ki trudeau and
merck
so i i
crafted
the compassionate use policy
that made it possible to get
this wonderful cancer drug
to about 6 000 patients before
regulatory approval and
you know we've probably about two
thousand people have their lives saved
uh based
based on that and then again moderna uh
as you mentioned
created by flagships so
i worked with modern in multiple ways i
was on their vaccine acceleration
committee and a consultant to the chief
medical officer but i also headed their
vaccine
ethics
committee and
uh brought that group together and as
you recall there in the beginning when
you're in very short supply there are a
lot of ethical issues about who would
get the vaccine who would get it first
so that's the other thing that drives me
so mike you've been at the the real
spearhead of of transforming uh
disease pathways or condition pathways
they're thinking about fosomax and
transforming the pathway for
osteoporosis protruder for cancer and
almost a new mechanism for vaccines with
the mrna
how how do you see the future of
medicine um and perhaps i could ask you
maybe to
tell us some of your thoughts on how do
you think it's been catalyzed if at all
by the pandemic
right
well that's a small question
how much time do we have
well um you know first of all there's a
big lesson that um
uh just a big general lesson which is
the importance of
invention innovation
so
every part of healthcare
can benefit from innovation
but there's a subset which
i call invention which are the things
that you can touch and feel
and they really have
the ability to transform medicine
and save lives and of course we've seen
that
in the pandemic imagine where we would
be
now if we didn't have vaccines
so huge impact and we saw that earlier
with the aids epidemic
we've seen slower epidemics like
cardiovascular disease
huge impact in there on statins so i
would say message number one is um
you can't get out of these giant
problems
without
invention if we didn't have that look at
alzheimer's disease it's the only way to
address it was to have
more nursing homes that operated more
efficiently
that would be a disaster but i'm hopeful
that we will get
some
some invention
that will either
arrest the development of the disease
prevent it or treat it so i would say
that's number one
uh number two um
examples of this are that the entire
definition of a drug
has changed radically
since
20 years ago
40 years ago there were only small
molecules then there were small
molecules and proteins like the hormones
biologicals antibodies
now of course we have things that
previously have never been seen on the
planet before we have
living cells
as uh as therapies we've got
gene editing we have mrna that we talked
about i'm optimistic that the microbiome
will yield
new therapies so
that's a second
part i think of the future of medicine
entirely novel
modalities um the way we go about our
business uh collaborating it's clear
that that the pandemic has really taught
us
that uh pulling together
is extremely valuable
and and productive
across sectors
and across
geographies and i think the aperture for
industry and where it will go in the
biopharma industry has really opened to
think about global health in the
developing world
and health disparities inside our own uh
developed world
uh societies
and then the last one where i don't have
an answer but it's got to be part of the
future is
preparing
for future
epidemics
and pandemics i think there's enormous
opportunity to prepare
based on the science
now available but there really isn't a
business model for making things
and putting them on the shelf
and
that's going to take public private
partnerships
it's going to take the kinds of things
that microsoft is doing to be able to
predict
what's coming and where is the best
place to go
to prepare so um figuring out
how to do that so that all sectors can
contribute i think that's part of the
future but it's a gigantic challenge
and you say how almost the definition of
the drug has changed i think the
definition of medicine is also changing
as we start thinking through
i remember having a conversation with
someone thinking about what is the
definition of medicine was that when i
was at medical school it was
around how do i diagnose someone and
give them a prescription to treat them
when i was at merck for a while medicine
was the drug it was it was all about the
pill itself and actually i wonder
whether medicine is the art of giving
people hope
because we may not always be able to
cure people but we can give people hope
and what we have is this future emerging
of precision therapeutics or precision
diagnostics powering the future of the
practice of precision medicine the
precision medicine is a combination i
think of everything that you've
described and hopefully leading to a
much more personalized state as we have
the emergence of more data around our
genome our biome our the economics
around which we live our social
determinants of health in addition to
what's in clinical records about us so
this explosion of data probably has
untapped potential around the
opportunities for collaboration and the
opportunities for improving health as
well
yeah well i i really like what you said
and uh
i've got two thoughts one is that you
are emphasizing the humanity
of medicine
and i always remember when i was just
starting out
in training
i remember a patient came into the
emergency room with severe asthma having
real trouble breathing
and um
so i immediately i knew which drugs i
was going to give that patient and jump
on it and there was a older attending
physician
uh there
and he said
you know watch this i'm going to get you
80 of the way there and he went over and
he just put his arm on the shoulder of
the patient and said you're having real
trouble breathing
but you know what we have the medicines
for you and you're going to be better in
just a few minutes and that patient
settled needed the medicines after all
but had a huge the humanity the humanity
of that moment
had a huge impact the precision medicine
is i'm with you i think that's where
medicine
is really going i think we're going to
be dissecting some of these complex
diseases that
certainly are more than one disease and
will be picking off
subpopulations and the best way to treat
them
as we start to develop drugs for those
sub-populations
they're going to be business model
challenges because the market is smaller
but
the work it takes to make a drug for a
smaller population is about the same as
to make a drug
for a bigger population so um
it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out
and maybe just to extend that then
um where do you think the biggest
opportunities are in the biopharma space
over the next 10 years so if you were to
have mike's crystal ball in front of you
and make a mic prediction we won't hold
you to this clearly
i'm just curious to think about where
where you think the biggest
opportunities are over the next 10 years
and i think you may have alluded to a
couple of these but i'd love maybe your
thoughts on that
well well i i hope you'll invite me back
in 10 years
uh
you know if i were starting out now
again
i think the opportunities in central
nervous system diseases the degenerative
diseases
and mental health
are enormous
and these are such huge unmet medical
needs
and the science is on the cusp it's
right on the threshold so i'm very
optimistic about that but but i think
that's where there's a great opportunity
and you know i don't want to take for
granted this precision medicine
opportunity we can approach patients and
you start at this part of the
conversation
in in a very different way in the future
and that's going to have great impact
hopefully it'll make
uh medicines better it'll make them
safer it'll eventually make them cheaper
and it's going to be much better for
patients
i think some complex disease is really
multifactorial but some complex disease
is just
uh that there's one simple thing but we
haven't uncovered it there's so many
different simple things
that can cause the disease
so i think we're going to have a way
into that
that we never had and it will by the way
it pairs very nicely with this notion
of therapeutic modalities that have
never been on the planet before because
you can apply them
to relatively small subpopulations in a
way that you can't imagine doing across
giant populations
brilliant and
and if i think about organizations like
microsoft or or big tech companies in
general
if you were to think about a piece of
advice that you might might want to give
so you've been
deeply involved on the the clinical side
deeply involved in the academic side
deeply involved in the life sciences
side
i wonder what your thoughts would be for
the big tech companies some of them who
have tried to engage in health care and
some of them have been more successful
than others but what would be your one
piece of advice to organizations in the
big tech side around how they could best
support the life sciences industry or
indeed the wider healthcare industry
well first of all would take great
hubris on my part to give advice to
microsoft research but you've invited me
to do so so i will and and maybe if you
indulge me in more than just one just a
few so so one so
uh
the discipline that you're in where you
are contributing and
can contribute tremendously in the
future is
medical information technology and the
use of
that information and i think there's a
danger of having medical with a small m
and i t with the cat with capital iq
and
so getting the m up there
i think
will have great payoffs and that
influences who you recruit
into the company into the research
division
and it also influences the kinds of
partnerships
you
microsoft undoubtedly has a problem that
i encountered in industry which is when
you go to collaborate
people look at you as a big atm machine
that's going to spit out money and
that's but what you're really looking
for are partnerships and choosing
partnerships
that will give you a capital m
as well as a capital i t so i would say
that's number one
um a piece of advice for me another
piece of advice is
that
i think the
in part because of the pandemic
the paradigm for evaluating
interventions and therapies
is kind of shifting you know the lens of
the reg of the fda anyway is
to approve drugs that are safe and
efficacious
well that just looks at the performance
of the drug is the drug safe and what
does the drug do
and it ignores and it did ignore until
the pandemic
what's the context that you're operating
in what's the risk of the disease
versus the risk side effects
of the drug
efficacy is fairly easy
to establish
but
the kind of data that you will have
access to and evaluate
i think really uh
changing the lens
so that we're looking at risk versus
risks risk of disease versus risk
of the intervention
and how that plays out over time in
individuals
can have huge huge impact
[Music]
and then the last thing i would say is
you know people are very interested in
looking at the natural history of
disease
uh using these very large clinical data
sets but one thing i haven't heard much
about that i think would be a value
is really understanding
who drug responders are and who the
non-responders are
going forward from the time of diagnosis
i think a lot of
expense
and time are wasted by doctors ancillary
health care workers
and patients
accruing side effects when they have no
chance of getting efficacy
in these groups and if we could really
say early on look the way you respond to
the first dose of something
is going to tell us
whether it pays to tither you over the
next six months
or we're going to have to switch you no
matter what i think we could have a much
better level of health care
and much
safer less expensive
if we could bring some of the tools
and analytic methods that you have to
bear
on uh
early predictions of who's going to
respond and who's not going to respond
amazing amazing
i'm if i just try and pull some of what
you've said together i'm reminded of a
quote from a book that's behind me it
was the book that i carried with me for
my first year in my house job so my
first year of residency and it says
medicine
um is almost an experience of your
imagination
so it
i think it you can take it wherever you
want to take it and i think what we're
what you've described to us is a the
career path can be so different you can
go from technical to academia to life
sciences and within life sciences and
within the context of your work be
involved in some of the biggest launches
and the biggest paradigm shifts in
medicine that can occur and the
opportunity for companies such as
microsoft or the big tech is to begin to
better understand the problems at hand
the humanity of what we're trying to do
within healthcare and then think about
whether those deep partnerships can
intersect leveraging the data at our
disposal to fundamentally impact on on
life so mike i'm sincerely sincerely
grateful for you taking the time out of
your tremendously busy schedule to be
with us and share your insights to this
community and i i thank you and i look
forward to continuing our dialogues and
continuing
to learn from you in a variety of
different mediums thank you again for
your time
well janae thank you so much for this
opportunity and uh i'm cheering for you
and your colleagues i think you're going
to have great impact
thank you mike